clark county just over a week away now
from its reopening plan good evening
thanks for joining us here at five i'm
denise feltes good evening i'm brian
loftis today they presented their
roadmap proposal to the state's covid
mitigation task force
8 news now reporter victoria saha
joining us live from our newsroom with
the
next steps to open up las vegas victoria
may 1st is that day many of you are
waiting for that's when clark county's
proposed plan to ease restrictions will
go into effect
and the state agrees this meeting comes
just a couple days
after clark county commissioners
approved a proposed plan
to ease coven 19 restrictions on
businesses and to help
daily activities come back to life in
las vegas in the new presentation to the
state
county leaders hope to increase capacity
to 80 percent
social distancing restrictions change
from six feet
to three feet however these rules can go
away once
sixty percent of the population gets at
least one vaccine dose
the plan had positive reaction from
caleb cage with the copen mitigation
task force there are no easy decisions
and you all certainly took these head on
and i just want to say thank you and
this looks like a
an excellent and um
thoughtful plan other changes would be
increasing how many people are allowed
at one table
if these plans are approved up to 10
people can be seated together
now that the plan has gone to the
state's covet 19 mitigation task force
it now heads to governor sislek as a
reminder even though local counties will
be taking over cobit 19 rules may 1st
the state mass mandate will still remain
in place
reporting live from the newsroom
victoria saha 8 news now